[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants savez vous ce que
notre nounours a fait aujourd'hui il est
allé dans la forêt tout seul au patro
que l' aventure jeu des seront vite la
raconter à nicolas il n'y a pas trop
belle
olé schell et au top up hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants où sont ils or vous
m'avez fait peur ce n'est pas le jour
si vous saviez tout ce qui m'est arrivé
aujourd'hui si vous saviez
si vous saviez quand je passais par le
bois le coucou chante et dans son joli
chant faisaient le couple et moi je
croyais qu'ils disaient qu puis le coup
copil tous et moi du conjoint sauvé son
vin et moi du goût j'avance au vert
[Musique]
quand je passais par le pré le faucheur
prochain et dans son joli j'en faisais
même pas quelle chaleur auquel chaleur
et moi je croyais qu'il disait à quel
voleur auquel voleurs et moi du coup je
manceau veut sombre et moi du coup je
mens sauvé quand je passais près de
l'étang canard alléchante on est dans
son joli show faisait et moi je croyais
qu'ils disent qu'ils aillent au coin qui
lie au point et moi du logement sauve
sombre et moi du coup j'ai mon sauveur
où sont ils passés chez innovant ya 22
janvier bonne nuit les petits poils de
du petit canard nino sera vite là j'ai
pas la lumière
bonne nuit nicolas pourrait aborder
[Musique]
partons sans faire de bruit nounours
tout notre petit monde dort déjà oui pas
trop sauf que je les hommes d'ennui des
enfants fait de bovins
où
à
[Musique]